so the day after the El Paso Texas
shooting Fox News not only avoided
telling us the shooters name which I'm
in favor of and I do as well they also
didn't tell us about the shooter leaving
an anti-immigrant white nationalist
manifesto they told us there was a
manifesto but for our own protection to
avoid glorifying the shooter to avoid
glorifying the motives of the shooter I
guess they were not going to publicize
the content of the manifesto and then
yesterday Fox and Friends literally
parrots one of the manifestos talking
points verbatim as fact about a
so-called Hispanic invasion complete
clown Brian Kilmeade called it a quote
fact that there is an invasion of
immigrants coming from Latin America now
just as a reminder all of our stories
this week even tangentially related to
the shooting have been demonetized by
YouTube so please consider supporting us
directly with a membership on our
website join pakman.com this is
important stuff to cover a youtube d
monetizes all of it because it is
apparently not in line with the whims of
advertisers so this is what the shooter
said in the manifesto that they hid from
us and then here is Fox News itself
repeating that exact same talking point
with the with the president has during
his two and a half years is a major
problem at the border which was not his
doing unless you want to blame President
Obama for the unaccompanied minors it's
streamed through here in 2014 when you
have over a hundred and ten thousand
people coming a month over a million
last year and then well over a million
this year if you use the term is as an
invasion that's not anti Hispanic it's a
fact
if the Russians were coming through
Alaska through Canada the president will
be using the same language but it's the
fact that's happening at the border if
you talk to people who are apolitical at
the border people want to look at the
words offense to invest in invest
infested or figure and look at the with
the president saying this is the
shooters manifesto presented by someone
with more media savvy
able
sort of round out and polish these ideas
Brian Kilmeade
and no-trump would not call Russian
immigration and invasion it's funny that
Brian Kilmeade actually suggests that on
Saturday as news of the shooting broke
Fox News interrupted its fear-mongering
on the Texas border to report an
anti-immigrant shooting on the Texas
border and here they are repeating the
same talking points that the shooter
included in their manifesto are they
this dense like do they not understand
that this is what they're doing or are
they doing it on purpose like is it
actually more insidious than even we
might think is it you know we don't want
to ascribe to malice that which we can
explain adequately with ignorance but I
don't know that ignorance actually
explains this it actually may be malice
Fox News and the white nationalist
shooter are on the same page we have an
invasion of Hispanic immigrants let me
give you a nice little throwback
refresher of who Brian Kilmeade is by
the way for those not familiar with them
this is a video of brian kilmeade
ten years ago basically doing eugenics
on fox news take a look
I did I'm just amazed they thought about
doing the study in the set but they by
interviewing people in the set in 1970s
in the 1980's 50 and they see that if
they keep it together
I find this I find this somewhat to the
fins and Swedes to come up with
something we are we're wearing we keep
marrying other species and other ethics
pure genes marry other Swedes because
that's the role Finland fins are the
Finns so they have a pure society in
America we marry everybody pro-white
eugenics on fox news they are part of
the problem and then I want to bring it
around sort of full circle part of the
problem is that they're simply
xenophobes and they are cow towing and
placating xenophobes
and the President of the United States
is doing the same thing and these
actions are having real-world impacts
like what we saw over the weekend
but there's another reason why massive
corporate media would even push this
narrative altogether and it's really
important to understand this is the same
thing as the immigrants are stealing
your jobs stuff when people are mad at
Hispanics for our problems
they aren't mad at corporations the real
reasons that wages are stagnant and the
middle class is shrinking and all of
this is not Hispanics it's huge
corporations taking advantage of
everything from immigration to tax law
while they foam at fighting between the
lower and lower middle and middle class
period you've got to understand that and
it's important you know when we cover
these things the shooting in and of
itself as a discrete and and a specific
event it's important to talk about the
motivations of the shooter and media
coverage of the shooting are
extraordinarily important to talk about
but when we step back for a second and
we look more broadly at immigration and
I've been trying to do this over the
last year and a half you have to
understand that corporations of which
big corporate media is a part have a
specific incentive to get people mad at
each other instead of at them because
they are the ones really benefiting it's
the corporations that benefit from
undocumented immigrant labor but yet
they are very happy to have you
believing the problem is a Hispanic
immigrant from Latin America who just
wants a better life for his family they
are not actually the problem this is all
part of that same narrative really
really important that we don't a sort of
lose sight of that I am thrilled to tell
you that today's episode is sponsored in
part by Blink accom slash Pakman Blink
astiz a really unique service for your
phone tablet and web browser and it is
incredibly useful for people like me who
love books and learning but are busy
blinka stakes the best and most popular
non-fiction books and condenses them
into 15-minute audiobooks I'm sure that
if you're like me you have a very long
list of books that you've been meaning
to
read you only have so many hours in the
day and that's why blink astiz so
amazing they take the most important
information the themes the insights from
each book and they distill it into a 15
minute audio book that you can listen to
in one sitting I've listened to a ton of
books on blink Asst our audience can get
a seven day free trial by going to blink
is calm slash Pakman if you're watching
on YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is calm slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com /pa que ma n